thanks to mack weldon for keeping legal
eagle in the air and helping me
look fly you hear it time and time again
when americans are told they should wear
a mask indoors
i'll just put you on my 3 000 follower
instagram feed mostly
hi everyone i work for costco and i'm
asking this member to put on a mask
because that is our company policy
so either wear the mask and i'm not
doing it cause i woke up in a free
country
a dallas woman decided to throw a
toddler style tantrum in a grocery store
not to be outdone by dallas a fort worth
woman berated a store clerk
i'm spreading more dark stays in here
for god's sakes
suddenly people have doctor's notes that
prevent them from wearing masks but the
same medical conditions obviously don't
stop them from screaming
and this california guy called the store
manager the n-word and had a meltdown
over the manager wearing a mask
this guy called me oh what
a totally shameless woman wants to call
the manager of a hospital
because the hospital requires that all
people wear masks
i was saying joseph's hospital they're
telling me that if i don't wear masks
they're not going to
assist me they want me to leave and the
people of florida weren't going to be
out floridaed by other states so people
in florida challenged mask laws because
only god can regulate breathing
and they want to throw god's wonderful
breathing system out the door
i was born free i will stay free my
rights come from god not from you
and some people have more practical
reasons for not wearing masks
i don't wear a mask for the same reason
i don't wear underwear
things gotta breathe then there's a
florida man who just doesn't feel like
wearing one
for reasons i just don't want to be
doing i don't know somehow sitting in
the oval office
behind that beautiful resolute desk the
great resolute desk
half of all states now require people to
wear masks in public spaces
obviously a lot of people are more than
a little confused about what rights the
constitution of the united states grants
to its citizens and what powers the
government has over its citizens
do you have an unalienable right not to
wear a face mask in public
can businesses tell customers to wear
masks and do those little cards talking
about the americans with disabilities
act
actually have any effect
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a toddler nope nope
it's time to think like a lawyer in the
beginning
god formed man out of the earth and
breathed
his breath in him and he became
a living soul where do you
derive the authority to regulate human
breathing well florida woman not
everything that you don't like
violates your constitutional rights for
example we have freedom of expression
but there are some things that we simply
cannot do like create obscene materials
involving children we have freedom of
assembly but the government may regulate
the time place and manner of how we
exercise that right when they have a
legitimate reason
in short our constitution recognizes
freedoms with limits
under the 10th amendment powers not
delegated to the federal government are
reserved to the states or to the people
this means that the federal government's
power is not unlimited so states and
smaller units of government have the
power to regulate certain conduct and as
we've seen throughout this pandemic the
federal government has taken
let's say a hands-off approach to
dealing with
covid with a federal government we're
not supposed to stand on street corners
doing testing
they go to doctors they go to hospitals
they go to the state
the state is a more localized government
you have 50 of them
and as a result most mass orders are
coming from mayors and governors
police powers are not unlimited but in a
pandemic governments have much broader
authority to impose regulations that
protect the population from a virus that
has serious implications for public
health
but at the same time citizens have
rights that cannot be taken away by any
particular laws
and if a law appears to interfere with
the constitutional right
those whose rights are affected can
challenge that law in court
constitutional rights include the
freedom of speech the freedom of
religion due process of law and equal
protection under the law
so because mask laws are so contentious
let's start with making an analogy
let's talk about government bans on
public smoking now if there isn't a
specific right
then it's highly likely that the
government can outlaw a certain conduct
take for instance bans on smoking
smoking is basically like wearing a mask
except it's the complete opposite
obviously the constitution says nothing
about a right to smoke for smoking to be
a constitutional right then it would
have to fall under one of the other
recognized constitutional rights
when government started banning smoking
in public places smokers actually
challenge those laws on two theories
one that smoking is a personal liberty
protected by the due process clause
constitution
or two that the equal protection clause
extends special protection to smokers
as a group now the due process clause of
the constitution prohibits the
government from depriving individuals of
liberty without
what's called due process of law this
means that a legislative body must have
an adequate justification for passing a
law that affects someone's liberty
smokers challenge these smoke-free
workplace laws in court on the basis
that the laws violated the due process
clause they allege that the laws took
away a smoker's liberty without adequate
notice or
reason but the courts uniformly rejected
this claim since the smoke-free
workplace acts
didn't involve a fundamental liberty
right such as the right to privacy
the courts used what's known as the
rational basis test to determine whether
the government could regulate
that particular conduct you can think of
it like a sliding scale the more a law
interferes with a fundamental right the
more scrutiny
a court will have in interpreting that
particular law and
the more it just involves regular
conduct that doesn't involve a
fundamental right well
the less scrutiny and that's generally
what the rational basis test is
often cases are won and lost based on
the particular test that is applied to
that law and generally if the court
applies a rational basis test
that law is almost certainly going to be
upheld the rational basis test requires
simply the law must be
rationally related to a legitimate
government goal
this requirement sets a very low bar for
the government a law will be considered
constitutional
so long as the law is not completely
irrational or arbitrary
basically laws never fail this
requirement for smokers this was very
bad news the government had ample
scientific evidence that smoking causes
health problems and secondhand smoke
harms other people who were exposed to
it
and smoking wasn't even a contagious
virus spreading without warning so at
the end of the day it was easy for
courts to uphold smoking bans because
there was a rational basis to connect
the smoking bans to
the legitimate public interest of
helping public health
so with that background let's talk about
covid19 mask
orders with copit19 the cdc estimates
that up to 35
of people infected have no symptoms but
are still contagious
and since masks reduce the chance of
infected people transmitting the
respiratory droplets that contain the
virus in enclosed spaces
mask orders are on pretty firm legal
ground and let's look at california
governor gavin newsom's mask order as an
example
governor newsom ordered people in
california to wear face coverings when
they're in quote high-risk situations
including inside of or in line to enter
any indoor public space
visiting a hospital or other
health-related building and waiting for
or riding on public transportation
or ride sharing vehicle now the
california emergency services act is the
source of the governor's power to make
masks mandatory the law gives the
governor broad authority to respond to
state emergencies like
the covet 19 panic the governor's
authority to take public health measures
was already approved up by the supreme
court at least temporarily when churches
challenged governor newsom's temporary
orders on large public gatherings
churches sued for an injunction barring
enforcement of the order
the supreme court denied their motion
for an emergency injunction
chief justice roberts cautioned that
courts shouldn't second guess emergency
measures that local governments imposed
for
health and safety especially quote while
local officials are actively shaping
their response to changing facts on the
ground
newsom's mask order relies on the same
law and rationale
so what if people sue um
dude why why you let everybody else do
it you know everybody else do you know i
can't do it because i'm a blonde white
woman
okay i think we have enough here
okay listen i might have you spin around
just put your phone down once okay
oh my god i'm sorry well people like the
woman in that video will certainly sue
newsome and other local authorities who
issue a mandatory mask order
representatives like kentucky's thomas
massey thinks that there's no way that
any patriot would ever wear a mask
or get vaccinated which would actually
be kind of funny if it weren't
so sad because george washington
conducted the first government-funded
inoculation in american history
when he had the entire continental army
vaccinated against smallpox
although representative massey and
others think that face mask orders are
unprecedented lunacy that americans have
never ever put up with how do i put this
nicely that is an
a historical interpretation face mask
orders were common during the 1918-1919
flu pandemic they were enforced with
citations and fines much like
authorities are proposing today
some people were even jailed during the
influenza pandemic there were even
influenza courts where people could
contest their citations
unfortunately there aren't really any
written decisions from that era we do
know that there were pockets of
resistance to mask wearing but the flu
pandemic was deadlier than world war one
which was
still raging at the time and most people
saw wearing a mask as part of their
civic duty when people did challenge the
citations judges
simply deferred to the government
regarding masks and closures
and that's basically what chief justice
roberts did even though the group of
churches
could cite to a specific fundamental
freedom in this case
religious freedom that theoretically
could have been curtailed or at least
implicated in these laws but the fact
that we're in the middle of a pandemic
really matters and there is one supreme
court case that should probably control
the outcome of all of these different
mask lawsuits in jacobson versus
massachusetts the court considered
whether the city of cambridge
could make a smallpox vaccination
mandatory the person who sued the city
alleged that the immunization
violated the equal protection and due
process clauses and violated the spirit
of liberty embodied by the constitution
but the supreme court held that the city
was well within its police power
authority to mandate this immunization
justice harlan rejected the claim that
each person is quote a law unto himself
and could act with no consideration
toward other people the liberty secured
by the constitution of the united states
to every person within its jurisdiction
does not
import an absolute right in each person
to be at all times and in all
circumstances
wholly freed from restraint since
smallpox cases were prevalent in
cambridge and the disease was increasing
the government was justified in taking
responsible measures to protect citizens
from smallpox
jacobson teaches us that for a lawsuit
against mass orders to be successful the
litigants will need to show that there
is no
rational basis for the law which is an
incredibly uphill
climb because there's lots of evidence
and arguments that mask
orders have at least a rational basis to
the legitimate aim of public safety
there are several strands of evidence
supporting the efficacy of masks
laboratory studies of respiratory
droplets concluded that masks can block
nearly all of the droplets
epidemiological studies like a recent
one published in health affairs have
concluded that masks slow the copin 19
growth rate
the study compared the covit-19 growth
rate before and after mass mandates in
15 states in the district of columbia
it found that the mass mandates led to a
slowdown in daily cobit 19
growth which became more apparent over
time
and there's lots of other data out there
that i could cite but a quick
google search will probably turn them up
but so far we've just been talking about
the states versus the federal government
kovit 19 has brought out a very
interesting if terrible
legal issue as between governors and
municipalities what happens if governors
and mayors actually
disagree with each other about covid19
orders or specifically
what happens when the mayors want mass
orders and the governors
say that there shouldn't be mass orders
the outcome of these conflicts depends
on how much power the cities have
under the home rule doctrine home rule
is the idea that municipalities and
counties
have autonomy to act with respect to
their own affairs
40 of the 50 states operate under
dylan's rule which means that
municipalities only have specifically
enumerated powers in other words the
municipalities like
cities and counties only have the power
that the state governments
actually bestow upon them this is why
georgia governor brian kemp filed a
lawsuit to stop atlanta and 14 other
georgia cities from making masks
mandatory
kemp asked a judge to overturn atlanta
mayor keisha lance bottom's orders
that were more restrictive than his own
block her from issuing additional orders
and instruct the city council
not to ratify her actions and force her
not to make any public statements
claiming
she has authority that exceeds kemp's
now so far the georgia mayors have vowed
to defy kemp's orders
and fight his lawsuit so that they can
actually make masks mandatory to stop
the spread of covet 19.
but in georgia the home rule says that
the city whether it's the mayor or the
city council
can only do the things that the state
government through the governor
allows them to do so it's likely that
they may lose those lawsuits
in contrast a few states give
municipalities significantly greater
police powers
in alaska which observes the minority
rule a home rule city
quote may exercise all legislative
powers not prohibited by law
or by charter so instead of a city
needing the power granted to them by the
state government the cities can do
whatever they want unless it's
prohibited by the state government
and anchorage issued a mandatory mass
rule in june
and although the governor's office tried
to limit the city's authority to mandate
masks in state buildings
alaska's legislature has not restricted
anchorage's authority regarding
mandatory masks or
exempt state-owned buildings this means
that anchorage's order
will likely stand so that's states
versus cities but by now you've probably
seen a lot of people claiming that mass
orders conflict with the americans with
disabilities actor ada
so what about people who claim they
cannot wear masks for health reasons
well title ii of the ada generally
prohibits eligibility and screening
criteria that would
tend to exclude individuals based on
disability unless the criteria
are necessary for the business to
operate safely in providing its goods
and services
those requirements must be based on
actual risks and may not be based on
speculation stereotypes or
generalization about people with
disabilities
businesses are safe generally in relying
on government mask orders and cdc
guidance
in refusing entry to people without
masks and
if a person without a mask enters the
ada only allows a retailer to deny goods
or services to an individual with a
disability if their presence would
result in quote a direct threat to the
health and safety of others but
only when this threat cannot be
eliminated by modifying existing
policies practices and procedures or
permitting another type of accommodation
and whether a customer poses a direct
threat is an individualized fact
sensitive inquiry but
you can imagine that during a pandemic
having an unmasked person
spreading potentially droplets that
carry the virus
could certainly qualify and that puts
businesses in a tough spot because
generally they need to accommodate
people with disabilities but they cannot
let that accommodation
directly threaten all of the other
customers but in many situations there
might be accommodations that can be
offered that
while it wouldn't allow a person to
enter a building without a mask on
they might be able to get the goods and
services in a different way for example
in
one scenario a manager offered a woman
accommodations that didn't involve
wearing a mask like
shopping for her okay so um what does
that look like
not allowing her into the building but
conducting the shopping on her behalf
now we tend to focus on the kind of
people who are clearly capable of
wearing masks but
choose not to either because they are
jerks or insane
the kind of people who claim that a
cloth mask will trap
the gas co2 and also prevent
the gas oxygen from getting into
your mouth that's that's not how that
works
but that's not to say that there aren't
people with legitimate
ada recognized disabilities that might
be incapable of wearing a mask
for example you might think of perhaps
someone with autism that
cannot function with restrictions over
their face which is why the ada
exists in the first place and that's why
accommodations
should be made if it's at all possible
things like online ordering contactless
deliveries curbside pickup and even
private browsing at a specific time are
all potentially reasonable alternatives
for
businesses to use but unfortunately
because
this is america it sure looks as if
millions of americans are suddenly
inventing medical reasons for resisting
mask orders without adequate proof
and as usual people are trying to make a
buck by selling identification cards
stating that the holder has a disability
and cannot wear a mask these face mask
exempt cards are
all over social media none of these have
any legal force whatsoever
even the federal government is wary of
these scammers the department of justice
issued a warning
that any flyer stating that people with
disabilities do not need to comply with
face mask laws are fraudulent especially
flyers that include the department of
justice's name and official seal
but businesses find themselves on the
horn of a dilemma on the one hand
they have to comply with the ada but on
the other hand they also can't be
negligent and
lead to the infection of a whole bunch
of other people there is a whole lot of
controversy over potentially making
businesses
exempt from liability related to covid
if
certain legislation passes but at the
moment businesses
cannot act in a negligent manner that's
how negligence works in the united
states and we probably as customers
don't want them to behave in a negligent
way and if they do
then they might be liable for damages in
causing
other people to get infected if they
acted in a negligent way
which is why in the absence of law to
the contrary
businesses can certainly require
employees and customers to wear
masks even apart from what is mandated
by the state or federal government
every single one of you that are obeying
the devil's laws
are going to be arrested not so fast
florida woman
businesses can require customers and
employees to wear masks and
some businesses have signs that you
might have seen that say no shirt no
shoes no service
that's because businesses can set their
own rules because they're
on private property as long as they
don't violate laws or public health
rules and
there's a certainly an argument to be
made that these kind of mask
requirements or
shoe requirements further public health
and don't go against it and so not
surprisingly this is specifically carved
out in the occupational safety and
health administration statute or
osho employers may choose to ensure that
cloth face coverings are worn as a
feasible means of abatement in a control
plan designed to address the hazards
from sars kovid 2
the virus that causes copid19 employers
may choose to use cloth face coverings
as a means of source control
such as because of transmission risk
that cannot be controlled
through engineering or administrative
controls including social distancing
you're removing our freedoms and
stomping on our constitutional rights by
these
communist dictatorship orders or laws
you want to mandate
uh no that's not how that works
masks are generally legal requirements
to wear masks are generally legal
but regardless of whether it's legal or
mandated
people use common sense wear a freaking
mask you can't tell by my words and
actions but i'm a christian
and the only person that's going to tell
me what to do
is jesus so since state governments can
in fact legally force everyone to wear
masks
you should at least wear the most
comfortable one and longtime sponsor mac
weldon has created what might be the
most comfortable mask yet
their masks use incredibly soft supima
cotton and plush ear holes
i guess ear holes ear things to make
social distancing safer and way more
comfortable
and they are guaranteed not to keep
oxygen out or
co2 in i just made up that last part
because
it's not actually a thing that you have
to worry about mack weldon's is an
essential men's clothing company that
focuses on smart design and premium
fabrics
if i'm not in court or on a zoom call
with a judge i'm often wearing mac
weldon i've tried their polos their
t-shirts their shorts
and of course they're world famous boxer
briefs and if you're watching this
channel
as an adult you probably deserve to have
nice boxer briefs and i can tell you it
makes a world of difference
i've ordered mac walden many times with
my own money i usually buy multiple
sizes and have them shipped to me and
then i just return the ones that don't
fit and keep the ones that fit perfectly
now if you'd like to try mac welding
you'll get 20 off of your first order by
just going to macweldon.com
legaleagle or using the promo code
legally eagle at checkout
and with mac weldon's loyalty program
you can get 20 off free shipping
and access to new products it's
automatic when you sign up and order at
macweldon.com
legaleagle so just click on the link in
the description or go to mac walden.com
legaleagle for 20 off of your first
order and of course if you want to try
their famous boxer briefs and you decide
for any reason that you're not satisfied
you can keep them and still get a free
refund because who wants to return used
underwear
so do you agree with my analysis are you
wearing a mask in public or
are you an idiot and or from florida
because god knows those two things are
not mutually exclusive
leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist over here
with all of my other law reviews where
i'm tackling the most important legal
issues of the day so
just click on this link and i'll see you
in court